they cover on average two-thirds of the
Earth's surface but scientists still
understand precious little about clouds
some believe they hold the key to
unlocking the mysteries of climate
change recently an unprecedented study
was launched to explore them it all took
place as far east as you can go in the
Caribbean islands the most ideal place
to do it and we were invited along for
an up-close look it's the dead of night
on the Caribbean island of Barbados but
for the crew of NOAA's Orion p3 aircraft
the day is just getting started
this hurricane hunter usually flies into
monster storms to learn how they grow on
this night we watched as the team
dropped remote sensors almost 60 of them
over eight hours
to gather scientific data about a
subject that only becomes visible with
the Rising Sun the white puffy cumulus
clouds this tropical region is famous
for maybe the crucial missing puzzle
piece for anyone trying to predict the
rate of climate change we don't
understand clouds can we ever be
accurate in climate modeling no you
can't because they're a huge part
climate system Chris Farrell is NOAA's
lead investigator for an unprecedented
six week long field science exercise
called atomic this is like the biggest
large-scale open-air cloud laboratory
Atlantic you're as far east as you're
gonna get here which is why Barbados is
is the spot to do this that's right a
sweet spot for doing your flooding the
atmosphere with just about everything
I can think of I mean it's it's it's
drones two one we brought out you know a
fleet of ships that's the idea just to
try to get as many different data points
right clouds may live in the air but
they're created by conditions far below
on and beneath the surface of the ocean
so to fully understand them you need a
ship how you doing okay no one has won
the Ron Brown a state-of-the-art
floating science platform this is a
heavily instrumented surfboard dr.
Elizabeth Thompson runs the science
program on board
it's a surfboard that's taking these
incredibly complicated measurements I
don't think a human would enjoy surfing
on it but the instruments do a really
fine job
the issue with tropical clouds as
they're really shallow so it's really
difficult for our satellites and get all
the properties of those small little
clouds right instead of relying on
satellites Thompson and her team unleash
dozens of remote vehicles across
hundreds of square miles of ocean for
six full weeks most of the heat in the
global climate system is at the equator
where the Sun beats down is the most
strong on the ocean surface and all that
he gets has to get dissipated somewhere
are like air conditioning systems clouds
are trying to redistribute energy the
global models that are tasked with
predicting sea-level rise in Florida how
hurricane strength will change in a
hundred years all of that is kind of
determined on how well we can predict
weather in the tropics the tropics
affects everything else yeah the rate at
which the earth warms is really
dependent on how these clouds work and
that's why we're here
my team has instruments were measuring
temperature humidity wind but Thompson
is not alone here the project is
multinational involving British French
and German scientists it's our most
sophisticated instrument including Bjorn
Stephens who's been studying clouds from
the Barbados cloud observatory for more
than a decade these photo clouds are
very interesting because they regulate
Earth's energy budget quite a lot so if
you change these type of clouds a little
bit it influences the climate and so as
the climate warms the real question is
what happens to these sorts of clouds
because if you feel a two-fold burst too
soon right
Stephens hopes the data collected here
will help climate scientists narrow down
the wide range of predictions about how
much the planet will warm and how fast
some have forecast a worst-case scenario
where these clouds and the protection
from sunlight they provide disappear
completely as we pump more co2 into the
atmosphere and that will lead to more
sunlight at the surface which will
enhance or increase the pace of warming
but the models treat these things pretty
crudely we're here to see if we can
figure out what's right oh here we go I
think we're already in the club there
you see clouds every day and you don't
think and what a massive role they play
unlike a guy that builds radars and
flies on airplanes it tries to
understand one cloud at a time I'm just
like one of the guys out there pushing
that my little rock up the hill you get
giddy when you're talking about clouds
yeah mr. cloud
all of it means Barbados typically known
as a destination for Sun seekers 2/3 is
quickly gaining fame as a place for
cloud hunters to mr. mr. cloud meso
villain maybe in a comic book but but
he's a hero in the in the scientific
community right now it's pretty amazing
some of the work they're doing down
there as they say what happens in the
tropics doesn't stay in the tropics no
they said the clouds are the
air-conditioning system for all of us
was there any big takeaway that they do
know already right now they're still
compiling all of this data it's gonna
take years to put it all together
I wouldn't necessarily expect a Eureka
moment but it's these incremental
advances they make as we understand a
little bit more about climate and about
what's happening every single day yeah
but just looking at the long game and
and and fearing what may happen with the
disappearance of our clouds it kind of
puts coronavirus into perspective
doesn't it I mean you this is an
immediate danger right now but this is
the long-term focus as concerned about
things like this too